dans les décombres d'un immeuble l'armée
ukrainienne filme l'un de ses soldats
montaient jusqu'aux toit pour faire
flotter de nouveau le drapeau jaune et
bleu au-dessus du village de
miroliubiska un village situé à une
trentaine de kilomètres à l'ouest de
Carson les forces russes à l'ouest du
flevenir auraient également perdu le
village de doutechanni même si elles
affirment avoir stoppé l'offensive
ennemie mais les troupes de Kiev
continuent bel et bien de gagner du
terrain sur le front sud dans cette
province toujours contrôlée à 90% par
les Russes qui viennent de l'annexé mais
c'est surtout sur le front est que la
contre-offensive ukrainienne est
actuellement la plus efficace
au total plus de 450 localités ont été
reprises dans la seule région de
quartier libérée grâce à l'opération de
défense qui a débuté en septembre et qui
se poursuit
elle se poursuit notamment dans les
provinces de données quai de luansk
après la reprise ce week-end de la ville
stratégique de Liman les troupes
ukrainien pas attendre de percer en
direction de sévero dognetsk et lycée
changsk tandis qu'une partie du
contingent russe s'est repliée vers
zatov et autour de Liman c'est la police
ukrainienne qui a pris le relais de
l'armée cherchons notamment des traces
d'exaction russe ici elle diffuse des
images de ce qu'elle présente comme des
cellules de détention et de torture